hello and welcome to Best Little Big
Planet 3 levels of the week I'm Lucy
this is Cam hello and together in
partnership with Sony we're here to
bring you this four-part video series to
highlight the best and brightest uh user
generated levels in Little Big there are
a lot of them there and we are slowly
picking our way through can't believe
we're at the the third the third episode
Le see I know crazy and we've only had
one Uncharted level this this week we
have you know what well we don't have
any more Uncharted level but you know
what's better than Uncharted giant
hamsters yeah we do have giant hamsters
hamers uh we also have actually we're
kind of on a hamster theme we are
because in the other level toggle's
technically a little hamster thing is he
yeah he has a little hamster whe and
then we're also having a level where we
fight and as we all know humans are
continually fighting against hamsters so
it's a hamster themed episode apparently
I don't know why but it was something
I've rolled with let's get to the first
level
[Music]
Lucy I'm still going a spatter in my
face what the hell um hard time
been how do I remove this this is
hideous awful it's the numbers Mason the
number the numers the numbers Mason what
do they mean l say I'm got a big
triangle in my face get it off get it
off get it off get it off get it off get
it off get it off get it off Pyramid
Head Pyramid Head stop oh that one's
really badly
placed it's like a a belly button belly
button right the belly button is where
it is I was made in a lab let's go to
our first level geometry man geometry
man I'll solve your problem with shapes
find X probably here it is all right
let's go you know what we don't do
enough of what's that L fighting we
fight a lot though like physical I have
brues so this is Little Big Planet 3
acrobatic rag doll fight amazing it
looks like what was that famous the game
which they then made
film again they made into a film you
know what I'm talking about rock and
sock and robots yeah that's exactly what
I meant yeah it's like rock and suck and
robots except it's weird mannequin
things remember that game that got made
into a film yes I do all right let's
look at the controls Real Steel let's
Okay so movement flips and acrobatics oh
right back kick back punch front kick
front punch and press all one to grab
your opponent you can only grab the so
long but your stamina will recharge over
time okay what do we want so Final
Destination boxing ring boxing ring let
keep it simple get here come here you
no I'm not very good at this oh I
grabbed you me out the ring with you out
of the ring let go yeah oh you got out
first oh you won cuz I landed first God
damn it how terrible is oh was he get
suicide yeah all best of something let's
go again nice nice it's like sweet fall
sweet fall there be beware of my throbby
fruit that's all oh what do I do jump
jump no no oh yeah come on no oh buff in
the face no no no no no don't do it you
stupid weird man all right let see you
won the first two but now it's just
about Knockouts so I think this is where
I this is where I my time to shine yes
punch I'm juggling in the face juggling
in the come on come on get up get up how
do I punch low okay kick kick yes I
going keep you a distance I'm just
getting you getting you in falling in
the face I'm going to oh God you're back
he's on the ro oh yes did you see it
what a move oh God I can't punch
backwards how do I I I hadn't thought
this far I can only attack the other way
I can only attack forwards I get off me
I'm going have to jump over you again
maybe if I lie down and put my head in
your ass oh wait here we go flip oh oh I
kicked you I flip blame you your easly
life give me oh God how come how come
you beating me cuz I'm really good at
game no
oh K God damn it you're the best it was
kick to the face kick to the face kick
to the back oh
no what have you done
bully the double kick I just turned into
a
dancer it's like it just wait what tap
all tap all I say
yeah I think we work ahead to win this
game how are you beating me again cuz
I'm really good at it this makes no
sense cannot ring out yes no you can't
ring out this but I can punch you into
aiv a well played again that's 40 all
right give me one more one more go final
bite all right I'm going to grab you so
it's 4 and punch you in the face grab no
come here you let's just hold hands
avoided oh no the kicks kicking me in
the crotch yes my it's mind you move
check this out they call it the
helicopter kick oh oh it's like Dirty
Dancing
won well least undefeated definitely the
victory of this except bam so that was
lbp3 acrobatic rag doll Fighter for one
to four players that would be fun with
more players that would be really good
with four play you'd still be robber i'
still be terrible um by Kevin XD well
done Kevin
XD what time is it cam it's it's hamster
time I think hamster hamster clock
hamster clar sorry hamster clock that's
what I meant to say uh this map's called
ham parad Lucy what's a hamper ad it's
this it's magical and we're gonna have
the best time oh really welcome oh no
you fell so this is just a quite a nice
little level oh god um someone's I'm
stuck uh where someone's made just a
parade of hamsters just there's a guy
fishing oh yes so there is my hamster my
hamster oh no no no no no shapes don't
help me swim at all oh the Collectibles
for me look I am a hamster on the road
look Nathan Drake there he is oh got hi
by car you got hi by car so it's like
hamster Frogger Prett good oh no you
fell off Jeffrey I fell off I no you've
taken Jeffrey and I'm I'm
dead in the power yeah but where all the
hamsters oh Lucy what to Shamy died well
there I am oh how did that even happen
um I don't even know hey I don't even
know how to don't know how to hit I
don't know how to hit I kind of feel
like um I'm the friending story this
this is a nice level it is just a bit
weird yeah it's really bizarre but oh
God a head car oh got a hit a car where
are we power my weird shaped legs you're
really scary I know you made me you made
me you made me you not make me so even
though we collected things this level
sadly doesn't it doesn't give you a
score so that was H parad I assume it's
h parade uh it's Japanese level from yam
p PT good job sir I liked it it was a
little bit a little bit strange but I
like
how let's go on to the next
level leing the final level of bomb
survival and we're oddsock we're OD look
how C look how adorable oh God go
collect them go on Lucy go collect itct
those things but don't collect the bombs
collect the bomb Lucy so this level's oh
no it's really fun basically bombs just
drop from this guy and you have to ooh
try and survive him um and then as they
keep going
down um I'm getting all muy it's taking
chunks out of watch out watch out chunks
out of the environment and then uh you
reach you know the the bottom this one
oh God I died oh you died that's
unfortunate for you a Ricochet explosion
all right hang on I'm going to shove all
the explosives down here yeah yeah yeah
wow the top score is like 21,000 I'm on
jump down there 1,000 oh nice oh that's
that's unfortunate Qui run run oh God no
you yeah you're all right you're right
you're right okay so the annoying thing
is I've got myself stuck in this hole
just try not to be nice to when it blows
up huh huh like right there like that's
the worst place to
be a you still K my ass yeah it was good
very good again again where did I come
oh just below YOLO swagon what swagon
for oh God I died again even my fault I
think my guy's just more vulnerable to
explosions than you are why because he's
got a cowboy I think there's more more
Target to hit
Cowboy oh how did you survive that that
was such a would killed me over here
Lucy no you oh you died oh that's a
shame for you come on I got to win I got
to win oh no don't jump next to the bomb
no no no you can push the boxes
oh
ow that wasn't fair at all oh
raspberries nice nice nice get out of
there I'm I'm like making a nest it's
good Let good the most dangerous Nest
ever ah you Nest that way I'll Nest this
way which way Nest way I'll Nest this
way you'll Nest left I'll Nest right
this way you Nest I'm nesting over here
this is good this is good I feel we
we've wor ahe to win this
level it it what have you done oh god
I've the same thing wait we lost our
Tower of tower of safety and joy push it
real
good just making a bomb Oh no I'm going
I'm done it well this didn't work we'll
meet in the middle that's just stuck
down there that's fine we'll meet in the
ow we'll meet in the middle see I'll
meet you in St Lou no you can do it you
can do it see keep tling they me jumping
oh that was good well we we'll jump to
look I'm just I'm heading them in ow no
no no I knocked me on to one oh no okay
I'm just like stuff's just bouncing off
bur of his nose he's like what of them
care I think I cracked it stuff's
Landing up my head oh no oh no cracked
it have
we oh I SP do oh you don't kick my ass
though well done uh so that's odd Sox
bomb level by G Pig 22 and it is a lot
of fun that was really good well you win
this week James did you beat Seb as well
um who won last week
I I'd like to say I did I think I did w
okay so we're going to say you won twice
huh God damn well I beat Seb so he's the
worst yes he's the worst me you you know
who's not the worst people who ask us
questions alth actually you kind of are
the worst because of the questions we've
got for this week about three of them
are mean so the first one is so uh yours
your last Light asks Lucy why is Lucy's
neck so long while her head is so small
why indeed Lucy I never realized I never
noticed this too I mean now it's all
like can see yeah I mean there's a
screen over there and just looking at it
my head does look a bit small next to a
Gira oh God what that's what you mean
what with a tongue that like comes out
to a you know but don't worry you're not
the only one who had people questioning
things about them referring to Seb um
Urban deadlock asks or says this guy
this guy's voice sounds just like War
Davis well War Davis has been in a lot
of great movies that's true true
a burn however I think this next one is
from the user The Watcher with the best
name ever the phos rapor says
philosophizes does the guy meaning Seb
also remind you of Allan from Two and a
Half Men John crier yeah kind of kind
maybe I never seen that before I'm
really glad I do that so that's good I'm
going to print something out it's been
highlighting but you know don't worry
just before you thought that all our all
our questions were dumb in comes mortos
tyranus there a dinosaur theme this we I
like it I love games that give you the
tools to create interesting levels I
hope more games do the same that's
awesome there you go things like Far Cry
4 especially like with the map editor
and you have a lot of fun with and yeah
little upon it there was a lot of stuff
to do okay it's time for the bit of the
show that was never meant to be a bit of
the show but then it was fun so it
became a bit of the show it's become a
staple it's this or that all right ly
this week I took the reins of the this
or that horse and we're going to go for
a ride through the the lovely Meadows of
the show are you ready metor okay no
okay hold on uh you should have said nay
you should have said n oh God all right
here you go here's your first this or
that you ready okay okay um the first
three are in relation to the levels we
did already so okay would you say you're
a lover or a fighter fighter hamster
prayed or the witch of three delayed
which are three delayed bomb Escape or
amorphous shape bomb Escape U hat bubble
or fat toggle fat toggle cheese or
pickle cheese bacon or sausage bacon tea
or coffee tea upfor sweep or cup of sip
upward swoop doubly jump or stubbly rump
stly rump power up or power puff power
puff medium molecule or speedier Oracle
medium molecule Lucy James or juicy
lames juicy lames forever SE for or Feb
sword FB sword user created levels or
loser mutated Devils loser mutated
Devils there we go that was this or that
for this week who was your favorite ly I
think ly James or juy lames yeah juicy
lames juy lames is great so don't forget
to send us your this or that suggest
questions using either the medium of the
comment box below or Twitter if you'd
like I'm at Lucy James games and I'm at
cam frz Rob send them to me to me or to
ready SE go which is of course a set
forward he's not here this week but
maybe he'll be back next week and if you
want to choose try redeem himself going
to need to and if you want to choose the
levels that Seb will ultimately fail at
then you want to send them to us over
Twitter as well using the hash GS
lbp3 which stands for Gamespot Little
Big Planet 3 or it may just be a
coincidence I don't know it be lucky if
it was just a random jumble of letters
very lucky yeah so uh and if you send
them to us we'll find them like like
pigs snuffling for Taste of Truffles and
we'll gather them all up and make them
into a delicious oil to put on your be
pigs do that really fancy Pizza yes pigs
pigs are very clever they're smarter
than I realized do the pigs make the
scientist pigs scientist pigs the
smartest of old the pigs well let see
let's find out more about science pigs
next week with another episode loing
Planet 3 l of
[Music]
oh